เฮ
[Música]
Olá, boa noite. Sejam muito bem-vindos
para mais uma live da comunidade
fechada. É um grande prazer estar
falando com vocês hoje.
Conforme vocês forem entrando, por
favor,
vão se identificando.
Boa noite, Rosiane. Boa noite, Dra.
Patrícia Dias. Boa noite, Alice Vogel.
E por favor, estou usando esse fone
aqui. Me dizem, me digam, né, se o áudio
tá bom.
Alice, está me escutando bem? Senão eu
vou trocar lá pelo outro microfone que
eu uso de lapela.
Eu vou ter que atender meu pai rapidinho
aqui. Me ligou no meio da live.
Alô, pai. Eu tô fazendo uma live agora,
eu te ligo mais tarde, tá bom?
Beijo.
O som tá bom?
Boa noite, Antônio Renato.
Vem ara
Oi, pai.
Hum hum.
Não, pai, mas eu já mandei entregar mais
para você. Não chegou não?
Eu pedi para mandar mais remédio para
você. Não chegou. Ped tem duas semanas.
Você
tem certeza, pai? Não chegou
que eu vou vou falar com a farmacêutica,
tá bom?
Mais tarde eu te ligo, então. Beijo.
Tchau.
Oi, vocês estão me ouvindo, né?
Então, acabou energia aqui no prédio e
voltou agora.
Tá, me confirma. Vocês estão me ouvindo,
né?
OK. Vamos lá, então.
Primeira pergunta do dia. Doutor, tenho
dúvidas a respeito dos melhores horários
para tomar suplementos. Sabemos que
alguns são melhores para alimentação,
outros já atrapalha a absorção de alguns
minerais, outros são melhores à noite ou
pela manhã. Tem como fazer um vídeo com
a indicação de como tomar os suplementos
mais consumidos? Eu tenho um vídeo sobre
isso, é porque vocês geralmente não
procuram no canal.
Então, a escolha do melhor horário para
tomar suplemento depende do tipo, se
você vai tomar a vitamina liposolúvel,
né? E também os outros nutrientes são
liposolúveis, como é o caso de vitamina
A, D, E com enzima Q10,
que mais
PQQ.
Esses lipossolúveis são melhores
absorvidos, né, com refeições ricas em
gordura, então almoço ou café da manhã
com ovo ou jantar.
Já as vitaminas hidrossolúveis, vitamina
C, vitaminas complexo B, é preferível
que sejam exigeridas com água e esse
tanto faz tomar em jejum ou tomar com
alimento, mas esses hidrossolúveis é
melhor, se for possível, dividir ao
longo de várias doses durante o dia e
também tomar cuidado de não consumir
vitaminas hidrossolúveis, que é o caso
da vitamina C ou do complexo B.
junto com fibras, que as fibras
atrapalham a absorção. O ferro tem que
ser associado à vitamina C, porque a
vitamina C aumenta absorção de ferro.
Mas é importante você, se for possível,
especialmente se for uma fera, uma forma
não queelada, você
distanciar o ferro de outros minerais,
como é o caso do zinco, como é o caso do
magnésio,
como é o caso do cálcio, tá? para que
esses minerais não tenha competição pela
absorção. E o ferro, o melhor horário
para tomar é à noite e longe das
refeições.
E o caso do magnésio, é interessante
você associar ele ao cálcio, porque ele
potencializa o metabolismo do cálcio.
Ômega-3, como é gordura, deve ser tomado
junto com refeições gordurosas. Mas se
você, por exemplo, quiser tomar vitamina
D ou outra vitamina liposolúvel, você
pode estar tomando junto com3, que um
ajuda o outro a absorver.
E polivitaminos vão melhor nas
refeições, de preferência evitando
fibras.
E no caso suplementos proteicos, como é
o caso de Wade, pósproteicos em geral,
aminoácidos, é bom distribuir ao longo
do dia e não tem essa necessidade tão
grande de janela de horário, mas é bom
tomar pós-treino.
Tem que lembrar da individualidade, caso
a caso, medicamentos que você possa
estar tomando, tá bom? Vamos partir pra
próxima pergunta.
Ah, achei dois vídeos dessa desta
profissional no canal do Fernando Betet.
Ela alega que os suplementos de ferro
não m, por exemplo, no porum só mascaram
os exames. Mascaram os exames? Não
entendi essa lógica. Ela indica uso de
cápsula de fígado bovino para resolver o
problema da de baixa ferritina
ou o próprio fígado bovino. Não é bom
sim comer o fígado, mas eu não entendi
essa história que o Noripurum Mascara.
É como se a gente precisasse de um ferro
bioidêntico para modular a ferritina.
Gostaria da sua opinião, tá? A minha
opinião, não sei qual é o raciocínio
eh desse profissional, né? no caso,
mas eu não vejo muito sentido nisso não,
tá? Eu tenho aqui paciente o tempo todo
com anemia acentuada, que às vezes a
gente não consegue resolver com
suplemento de ferro oral e tem que fazer
o noripurum. Tem noripurum oral, mas
geralmente eu passo mais o noripurum
endovenoso, tá? E funciona muito bem,
tá? Então eu não sei
bem o que a pessoa quis dizer, tá?
Então tem um problema de absorção, é um
detalhe importante. Nem sempre absorção
do intestino é eficiente. Por isso que
eu até comentei da vitamina C junto com
ferro agora a pouco.
Se a pessoa tiver disbiose, gastrite ou
doencelica, pode acontecer de não
conseguir absorver o ferro não m, né?
A questão de mascarar talvez seja por
conta de que você toma o ferro
medicamentoso, ele pode elevar o ferro
cérico rápido, mas não vai levar a
ferritina na mesma velocidade, né, que é
o verdadeiro estoque de ferro do corpo.
Talvez seja por isso que ela tenha
falado isso.
Então, é importante que o intestino
esteja funcionando bem para absorver bem
o ferro dos alimentos ou dos
suplementos. Então isso tem que ser
levado em consideração. E eu concordo
com a história do fígado ou da cápsula
de fígado desidratada. Agora, eu não
conheço empresa no Brasil que trabalha
com cápsula de órgãos hidratada. Eu
conheço uma na Nova Zelândia, no Brasil
não sei se tem,
tá?
Fígado vai ter vários outros nutrientes,
né? Além da
do ferro, né? Esse que seria a vantagem.
Então, no por um que eu prescrevo que na
clínica muitas vezes ele é na veia ou no
músculo,
tá? Essa que é minha experiência maior
com o porum.
Vamos partir pro próximo.
Paciente com 85 anos, queixa de perda de
memória mais ou menos um ano. Qual o
conselho de como proceder?
Tá bem resumido isso aí. Primeiro que,
óbvio que você sabe que o objetivo aqui
não é ficar fazendo consulta informal, é
é só dar dicas, né?
Então esse paciente é um grande
candidato a fazer o protocolo recod.
Então, seria dieta ketoflex, jejum
intermitente, atividade física,
tanto aeróbico quanto de força, seria
treinamento cerebral, seria
gerenciamento do sono, gerenciamento
estresse, detox e suplementação,
tudo isso, tá? Então, é muita coisa para
falar aqui. A gente tem 20 e tantas
perguntas para responder, então eu não
vou entrar em tanto detalhe, tá?
Mas dá uma olhada nos vídeos sobre o
protocolo recode. Eu fiz um uma live
recente agora com o Rodrigo 25 que a
gente tocou nesse assunto. Você pode
começar por essa live, depois vê os
vídeos mais antigos que eu falo sobre
isso, tá? Mas grosseiramente falando, dá
uma olhada nas deficiências aí de B12,
vitamina D, de ácido fólico, vê se não
tem hipotiroidismo, vê se não tem
depressão, veja se não tem de déficit de
audição que atrapalha a cognição, vê se
não tem apia sono, vê se não tem foco
infeccioso na boca.
Tudo isso tem que ser tratado. Vê se não
tá com problema aí de circulação
cerebral,
vê se não tá com infecção oculta,
tá? É muita coisa, tem que ver.
E tem uma série de suplementos que
aumenta o BDNF e o NGF, né, que são os
principais aí fatores neurotróficos.
Mas aí é um assunto muito vasto e muito
amplo para ficar falando aqui numa
pergunta rápida.
É aquela história toda, vitamina D, ô3,
B12, fófidil colina, é muita coisa, tá?
Vamos, vamos continuar aqui. Gostaria de
saber a fórmula certinha com a posologia
do euro molecular falado na última live.
Essa pergunta se repete, tá? Eh, tá, tá
falado no vídeo, eu não sei porque que
vocês não entenderam, tá? Você vai
calcular 500 microg mais ou menos de
iodo no total. Desse total, 2/3 vai ser
iodeto e 1/3 vai ser iodo molecular. É
basicamente isso, tá?
Eh, então vai ser
mg de iodeto
e mais ou menos 175
mg de iodo molecular. OK? Então, 2/3 de
odeto, 1/3 de iodo molecular para
completar 500 mg. Por que não o lugol?
que olugas
gotas já vai ter vários miligramas de
ouro. Essa que é a questão, tá bom?
Espero que tenha ficado claro isso aí,
mas a gente pode voltar nesse assunto
caso vocês
não estejam ainda entendendo sobre isso.
Lembrando que microgramas é menos de 1
mg, né? Então 1000 microg é igual a 1
mg.
Vamos partir pra próxima.
Qual que é a dosagem de vitamina D3 para
criança de 1 ano? Eh, 200 unidades por
kg, tá? 200 unidades de vitamina D3 por
kg.
A K2
eu não lembro agora. Eu acho que não tem
uma dose padrão para K2.
Eu daria 100 microg porque é muito
segura a vitamina K2, tá? E agora que eu
saiba, não tem uma recomendação formal
por peso por criança de K2,
mas é importante também entrar com o
magnésio, tá? Junto com isso aí. Quando
for dar D3, dá K2 e o magnésio juntos.
Aí eu daria
de magnésio mais ou menos uns 100 mg
para uma criança de 1 ano, tá?
seria essa dose, 100 mg do do mineral
elementar, né? Tem que fazer a conversão
para cada tipo de magnésio.
Ã,
os isolados de K2, MK7 seria indicado
como profilaxia para calsificação dos
vasos? Sim, pode ser feito isolado, sim,
mas eu associaria a vitamina D com a K2
e o magnésio, como acabei de falar.
E a K2, sim, ela é interessante, ela
ativa proteínas da matriz GLA
que inibam o depósito de cálcio nos
vasos sanguíneos e ajuda a direcionar o
cálcio pros ossos e pros dentes.
E tem tem estudos, como é o caso do de
Rotterdam, que associam o consumo de K2
com menor incidência de doenças
cardiovasculares em geral e menor
incidência de calcificação vascular.
Agora, se for para reversão, aí você vai
ter que associar outras coisas e vai
demorar uns dois anos para isso
funcionar, tá?
Você teria que tá associando a nquinase,
pquenol,
tá associando
a precursores do óxido nítrico, né, como
é o caso da citrulina, morvaline S7, que
é um blend de fitoterápicos que ajudam
aumentar óxido nítrico,
tá? Então é um pouquinho mais complexo
aí.
Qual o melhor horário para tomar cor e
biome? Não tem melhor horário. Você pode
começar tomando de manhã e depois tomar
até até três vezes ao dia, se quiser.
Eh, geralmente é tomado ele logo antes
ou logo após a alguma refeição, mas não
precisa ser uma refeição específica,
pode ser café da manhã, almoço ou
jantar.
Mas a maioria das pessoas acaba tomando
antes ou depois do almoço e do jantar,
tá? A dose mínima é 300 mg, a dose
máxima é 900 mg.
A literatura destaca que tomar próximo
das refeições vai ajudar a otimizar a
absorção e o aproveitamento do butirato
no trato digestório.
E óbvio que você sente como é que seu
corpo tá reagindo e você pode fazer
individualização
de acordo.
E muito obrigado pelas palavras aí de
agradecimento, tá?
Boa noite, Dalan LAN. A título apenas de
uma dica. Qual seria a dosagem mais
indicada para sexagenários da
metobalamina, metfolato peridoxal? Isso
é variável, tá? Grosseiramente falando,
você pode tá usando entre 500 e 1000
microg, ou seja, de 500 microg a 1 mg de
área de meticobalamina.
Preferencialmente soblingual.
O metiofolato vai ser na faixa também,
na maioria das pessoas, entre 400 microg
e 1 mg. Algumas pessoas tomam 2, 3, 4, 5
mg, mas tem que começar com dose baixa.
E o peridoxal 5 fosfato,
geralmente eu passa entre 50 e 100 mg
por dia.
Peridoxal c fosfato é formativa da B6,
tá?
Então, em dos geralmente eu subo um
pouco mais a dose, tá? Porque a absorção
nessa faixa de idade é menor, tá? E é
interessante fazer uso contínuo, ou se
não fizer contínuo, fizer exames para ir
acompanhando.
Exames seria a dosagem B12 no sangue.
Você pode dosar também o ácido
metilomalônico que é mais preciso.
Quanto maior o metilomalônico, menor a
B12. Quanto maior a B12, menor a o
metomalônico. Então ele vai acompanhando
ao contrário a B12, tá? E a homocisteína
também é um bom marcador. Aí geralmente
ela sobe quando a B2 está baixa também.
Então é mesma situação do metimalôico.
Aí é um marcador que tanto mostra
mitilação quanto inflamação.
Então a gente nem sempre consegue
corrigir a uma alta com a B12 isolada ou
cometi folato mais B12. À vezes tem que
associar B6, B12, B9 mais colina, mais
NAC, mais trimiticina, mais ôga-3, mais
inconteir
um sistema.
Ah, boa noite. Seguindo sua orientação,
mandei manipular 500 mg de tributirina.
Deve estar falando do corbiôme, né?
Porque o pessoal confunde tributirina
com eh trimebina,
tá? quase igual a palavra, a trimebutina
é um remédio para intestino irritável, é
um sintomático, como se fosse um buscopã
e a tributilina é o corebiô, tá? Eh,
para 30 dias, uma cápsula por dia, não
havendo reações adversas, pode aumentar
por 1 gama, a dose máxima é 900, tá?
Segundo o fabricante, eh, começa com 300
mg e vai até 900 mg, mas 1 g, 900 mg
é praticamente a mesma dose, né?
Mas essa seria a dose máxima, né?
Importante você fazer isso com
acompanhamento de nutricionista ou
médico.
Tomar cuidado que pode ser raro, mas
existe possibilidade de ter alergia, né?
Ou algumas interações aí não previstas.
Que que é esse filtro aqui? Nem eu sei.
Ah, tá.
Ah, nem precisa disso aqui não. Vou
colocar. Pronto. Acho que fica mais
bonito. Tomo L carnitina 1 g com enzima
Q10 200 mg. PqQ 20 mg. Quero acrescentar
se tira de carnetina 2 g. Cozima que é
10 100 mg. Há algum problema?
Ué, não entendi. Tá tomando 200 de
cozima, quer tomar 100 agora ou ou quer
aumentar para 300? Não ficou claro isso
aí.
Mas a princípio não, tá? São coisas bem
seguras aí de canetina com enzima, PQQ,
tá?
Não vejo nenhum problema quanto a isso
não.
E a cararnitina é um pouco diferente da
cetilcarnitina, tá? A cetilcarnitina é
mais cara, ela atravessa a barreira
hematoencefálica ou hematolicórica.
Elcarnitina não atravessa a barreira,
então faz sentido associar os dois, tá?
Enquanto cetil alcanarina vai ajudar na
pfum cerebral, a elcarnitina vai ajudar
na energia do resto do corpo,
principalmente muscular.
Então a cozin é muito segura, a PQQ é
muito segura e não vejo problemas, nunca
vi ninguém ter reação forte com esses
suplementos. Agora, só para saber, eu
não me lembro de ter visto isso, mas
existe relatos de sintomas
gastrointestinais leves como náuseia,
mas eu nunca vi, tá?
Isso acima de 300 mg por dia de coisa
maquia 10.
Bem, vamos pra próxima. Posso misturar
semente de sucra com erva baleheira, mas
erva de São João cuidado com erva de São
João, tá? é um dos fitoterápicos mais
perigosos assim, sem a assistência
médica. OK.
Ah, você poderia fazer essa mistura
cometí cupira, ervaira e erva de São
João para fazer um extrato em álcool de
cereais,
só que também muito cuidado.
Tenha certeza que a planta é essa mesma,
porque às vezes você compra uma planta
dizendo que uma coisa é outra. tomar
muito cuidado com isso.
E o álcool de cereais é realmente o
solvente indicado para tinturas, né? Ele
é bastante utilizado para extratos
fitoterápicos.
Ele é bem seguro.
[Música]
Então, tome só cuidado. Eu tomaria muito
cuidado com a São João, que é o
Ipéricum, porque ele é uma planta que
pode ter toxicidade, tá bem? Se você
fizer isso, coloque num frasco de vidro
escuro.
Então, tome cuidado com a diluição
também para não ficar muito concentrado
o álcool, tá?
Agite o frasco diariamente para
homogeneizar
e de preferência faça isso com
acompanhamento profissional.
Pode tomar glutamina, creatina, limão e
própolis, tudo junto? Pode, que seria um
problema nenhum, né? Glutamina vai muito
bem com creatina, porque glutamina dá
suporte pro intestino, sistema imune. A
creatina vai dar suporte energético e
cerebral. própries vai melhorar o
sistema imune junto com a cutamina. O
limão tem vários nutrientes
interessantes aí para como
antioxidantes.
Não tem nenhuma contraindicação de
juntar esses não.
Inclusive é muito comum a associação de
limão e própolis, né, para questão de
sistema imune.
E a glutamina vai ajudar nisso.
Cuidado só para não ter doses excessivas
demais de própolis ou de creatina.
Creatina é muito segura até doses altas
assim, 8 g por dia, 10 g, mas pode
aumentar a creinina no sangue, né? E dar
aquela sensação que tá dando insistência
renal, que não é verdade. Então tem que
tomar cuidado só com isso daí, né?
Porque dá uma falseada nos exames de
função renal.
Quando se tem colesterol total alto,
mais tricérides baixos, isso indica que
predominantemente esse colesterol é
divindo de fontes saudáveis.
Não é bem isso não, tá? Eu explico isso
em vídeos, tá?
Na verdade, o que acontece é que o LDL
colesterol, ele tem uma fração boa, tô
falando de LDL, tá? Ele tem uma fração
boa e uma fração ruim. Então a gente faz
uma continha, o triglicérides, ele tem
que tá aproximando, tá, do HDL. Então,
digamos, o HDL tem que estar 40, no
mínimo em homem, no mínimo 50 em mulher
e o trigglices um pouco abaixo de 100.
Essa que é o é a conta que a gente faz,
tá?
Mesmo que você tenha um colesterol total
considerado alto, ou seja, um colesterol
total, sei lá, de 220, mas se você tiver
um HDL de 60 e um trigé de sei lá, de
80, mesmo com esse colesterol
considerado alto, não é considerado
ruim, porque a gente sabe que devido a
essa conta tá favorável aí entre o
triggices e o HDL, você vai ter uma
predominância de LDL de partículas
grandes e flutuantes e não de partículas
pequenas e densas, porque são as
partículas as pequenas e densas de LDL
que causam até esclerose, tá?
Esse LDL pequeno e denso que vai oxidar
e vai glicar e vai causar problema na
parede das artérias.
Geralmente quem tem resistência
insulina, a insulina ou res insulínica
tem triglicides bem altos, tá?
É interessante se você puder fazer
medida da polipoproteína B, da
apolipoproteína A, se conseguir fazer de
LDL oxidado, melhor ainda, tá? Isso tudo
são marcadores mais precisos.
Doutor, seja sincero, precisa viver
muito saudável, só comendo frutas? Como
assim comer só fruta?
Hum. Não, não acho que seja viável comer
só frutas, não.
Poderia ser bom ter fibras, seria bom
ter antioxidantes e vitaminas, mas tem
antinutrientes também nas frutas. Se
você comer sua fruta doce, você vai ter
uma sobrecarra de frutose que vai
sobrecarregar o fígado.
Eh, vai ter muita falta de determinados
nutrientes, porque as frutas não são
grandes fontes de vitamina B12, não são
grandes fontes de creatina ou de
aminoácidos. Então, faltaria muito
aminoácido aí, muita proteína de alta
qualidade, faltaria gorduras essenciais
eh pro organismo, né, como ômega-3 e até
ômega-6 precisa, né, não pode excesso de
ômega-6, mas ôega 6 é importante pro
organismo. Faltaria ferro, faltaria
zinco, né? As frutas não são fontes de
zinco, tá? Então, realmente não daria
certo só comer fruta, não, tá?
Todas as regiões que têm grandes
longevidades, como é o caso das zonas
azuis, né, que a gente conhece aí da
literatura, a base alimentar ela é rica,
tá? Não é só fruta, você tem que comer
vegetal, você tem que comer leguminosas,
você tem que comer oleaginosas, gordura
saudável, proteína animal, tudo isso
entra na dieta das regiões aí das zonas
azuis,
tá? Então, só comer fruta exclusivamente
não daria certo.
Fala sobre alfalipoico para dores no
corpo. Alfalipoico não é bem um
analgésico, tá? ele vai ter um efeito
antiinflamatório indireto, porque ele é
um antioxidante.
O efeito dele que a gente mais usa é
para diabetes e para pessoas que tá com
deficiência de funcionamento no fígado.
É muito bom também para problemas
neurológicos, dor neuropática,
mas aí o efeito dele vai ser indireto,
vai ser um efeito de melhorar o neurônio
e desinflamar o neurônio, mas ele não é
bem um analgésico, tá?
Se é uma pessoa que tem dor na
panturrilha, pode ser várias fontes.
Pode ser uma dor muscular, pode ser uma
dor neuronal, pode ser uma dor vascular.
Se for uma dor vascular, por exemplo, o
alfalipuco não vai ter muito efeito,
não.
Agora, se for uma neuropatia diabética
com dor na proturrilha, o alfalipoico
vai sim ajudar muito nesse caso,
tá? É bom que vocês entenda isso. Ele
vai ajudar na resistência urínica.
desinflamar nervo, ele vai ajudar como
antioxidante, mas ele não vai atuar como
se fosse uma dipirona. Ele não vai ter
esse efeito, tá? Ele vai ajudar também a
regenerar o tecido nervoso.
Agora tem que investigar qual é a causa
da dona panturrilha. Se for, por
exemplo, domuscular, o alfalipuco ele
vai ajudar pouco,
tá?
Então tem que fazer uma consulta para
investigar isso.
Boa noite. Assiste seu novo interessante
vídeo sobre experimentação com iodo e
gostaria já de agradecer o conteúdo.
Pelo que entendi, uma formulação de iodo
complexo que contemplação iodeto. Já
acabei de falar sobre isso, né? Mas eu
acho que as pessoas se interessaram
muito por esse assunto e não sabiam que
a outra tinha feito a mesma pergunta.
Ah, contempla as formas deeto e
molecular seria tão completo quanto o
Lugol? E, a questão não é ser completa
ou não, a questão é a quantidade, né?
Como eu falei, é mais ou menos 300 mg aí
de
iodeto, mais uns 200 mg de iodo
molecular. Seria essa mais ou menos a
conta aí, tá?
Estou interessado, exterando suplementar
comíodo complexo na dose. Aí, ó, você
até mesmo colocou a dose aí, ó, né? Ah,
poderia indicar farmácia confiável,
integritar, tá bom?
farmácia integritar.
Eu já conversei com eles, eles têm como
fazer esse essa formulação.
Na atualidade estão circulando alguns
protocolos para serem usados juntamente
com os tratamentos convencionais em
pacientes com câncer que incluem
vemeectina combinado com fambazol e
doses altas. Esses protocolos são
baseados em estudos de casos e não
existem estudos randomizados que eu
tenho conhecimento. Sim, você tem toda a
razão. Tem toda a razão.
Qual seria a sua opinião em relação a
esses protocolos?
E dentre os profissionais que estão
divulgando esses estudos, quais seriam
os mais confiáveis?
Aí eu acho que o ponto não é qual é o
profissional que é mais confiável, menos
confiável, porque o que tá sendo
divulgado aí, Marilda,
são protocolos praticamente idênticos,
né? Quem tá divulgando muito isso a
nível internacional é o William Max, que
é um é um oncologista canadense. No
Brasil, a pessoa que é mais conhecida
nisso é a
doutora
Luciquer, né? Porque ela ficou muito
famosa na pandemia por causa da dos
estudos dela com a evimectina.
Mas eu todo mundo tá passando
basicamente a mesma dose. O
a vimetina é de 0,5 a 2 mg por kg, mais
nessa faixa de 1 a 2 mg/ kg. E o
fembrendazol, e membrandol tá na faixa
de 888 até 1500 mg por dia. E tem gente
que faz intervalo no final de semana,
tá? É basicamente isso. Eh, e realmente
os estudos são só em vitro
e em cobaia. Você não tem estudos eh
clínicos, tá? Mas a evidência
pré-clínica até alta. Então tem muita
gente que tá, entre aspas, arriscando
usando
vimectina como medazol ou febendazol,
porque essas pessoas geralmente estão
com metáas de distância, já estão
desenganadas, já estão numa situação que
justificaria você fazer uso eh
compassivo dessa medicação, tá? Mas é
polêmico, sem dúvida. É polêmico. Tem
gente que vai dizer que não vale a eh
não tem evidência suficiente para usar
em um ano, mas como são medicamentos já
muito antigos, que as pessoas já usam h
muitos anos para parasitose
e teve uma experiência também grande na
pandemia, então as pessoas se sentiram
mais confortáveis de utilizar, tá?
Porque a toxicidade é muito baixa mesmo,
tá? Ao contrário do que muita gente fala
aí que falaram durante a pandemia, né? A
imprensa falou que divulgou muito que a
VMCina poderia ser patotóxica. A gente
não vê isso na prática, tá? Nunca vi
nenhum caso de patotoxicidade mesmo dose
alta de vimectina.
Então os estudos que a gente tem são até
sólidos pré-clínicos, né? Não os
clínicos. A gente não tem realmente
estudo clínico, mostrando vários efeitos
antitumorais, né? Eh, questão de indução
de apoptose, efeito antioxidante
antiinflamatório,
modulação do microambiente tumoral. Só
que se você for perguntar para
oncologista ou paraas sociedades aí
oficiais, eles vão dizer que é absurdo
usar esses antiparasitários,
não tem comprovação. P p p p p p pá.
Vocês sabem como é que é a história, né?
E tomar cuidado, né, gente, que o
pessoal exagera, começa a dizer que
trata tudo, cura tudo, não sei o que lá.
E isso é muito comum, infelizmente, né?
Tem que ter bom senso.
Doutor, como saber quais suplementos
devem vir em cápsula gasto resistente?
Depende se for um suplemento que agride
o estômago. É simples assim, né? Se for
um suplementos que quando bate no
estômago eh queima, vale a pena fazer em
cápsula gás resistente. Um grande
exemplo é o zinco. Outro grande exemplo,
alfalipoico, são suplementos que
geralmente não são muito tranquilos no
estômago, tá?
E também as capas gas resistentes são
importantes para ativos que se degradam
em páco, ou seja, perder a potência se
tiver contato com o ácido estômago.
Por exemplo, é o caso de alguns
probióticos.
Então, mas a maioria dos suplementos não
precisa ser gasto resistente, pode ser
cápsula comum, porque acaba encarecendo,
né, a manipulação.
Tem alguns minerais que vão absorver
melhor e pegar ácido, então, tipo
magnésio, zinco, ou cobre, então é bom
que eles ionizem com acidez do estômago.
Então, nesse caso, não é bom você
colocar ideia, a não ser que você seja
sensível ou zinco, né? né? Nesse caso,
tem que ser uma uma cápsula
gastroistente.
Geralmente elas são feitas de gelatina
animal
ou celulose ou de tapioca. essas
cápsulas aí de gastos resistentes.
E se a composição da cápsula pode fazer
mal à saúde? Geralmente não faz mal à
saúde, tá? Porque o componente da
cápsula é o fitalato de hipromelose
e geralmente é seguro, tá? A não ser
seja pessoas muito sensíveis que tm
aquela símbolo de tolerância hitamínica,
tá? O mais comum não é nem a cápsula da
problema, mas é a o excipiente, que é o
enchimento, tá? Que são corantes de
óculos titânio, pode ser talco, né? Isso
aí que geralmente dá mais reação.
Ã,
acho que eu respondi, né? Então os
minerais é melhor que seja em cápsulas
comuns, a não ser se tem a sensibilidade
ao zinco, que é comum também, tá? O
restante você poderia também fazer
vitaminaosolúvel em cápsula comum,
precisa ser DR caps ou cápsula
gastroistente.
Boa noite. Dialogando com a IAP de a
diferença entre magnésio glicina e
magnésio bisiglicinato, de forma
resumida, me retornou magnésio glicina,
mistura de magnésio glicina.
Não totalmente queelado. Parte do
magnésio tá ligado à glicina, parte está
em forma inorgânica e magnésio
bisclicinato, magnésio totalmente
queelado com duas moléculas de glicina,
mais ou menos, tá? Para muitas de
manipulação, eh, as duas formas são
equivalentes. Então, quando você coloca
glicina, eles entendem que é
bisglicinato, mas o jeito mais técnico
de falar é magnésio bisglicinato mesmo,
tá?
Com isso, acabei chegando ao Albion.
Albion é uma marca de
que fornece, né, para as farmácia de
manipulação. É um fornecedor muito
conhecido, muito antigo, que tem as
formas queeladas, né, que a o
bisglicinato seria uma das formas que
aqueladas.
Ã, sim. Na verdade, se uma farmácia for
idônea, ela vai vender o magnésio. Se
você pedir magnésio, glica, eles vão te
entregar magnésio bisclicinato.
Mas essa explicação da IA tá correta,
tá? É bem isso mesmo.
Porque acontece o seguinte, tem gente
que é pilantra e coloca assim magnésio,
glicina, magnésio tronina tentando
enganar a galera, porque aí não é bem o
magnésio queelado, é o magnésio na forma
de óxido cloreto junto com aminoácido e
não queelou mesmo, não juntou os dois,
tá? Hoje mesmo dia um paciente que tava
tomando magnésio, glicina, mais
treonina, né? E o fabricante tava
tentando enganar ele que era o magnésio
treonato, mas não é porque não tá
aquelado, entendeu? É só o minócito
junto com o magnésio. Não sei se vocês
estão entendendo o que eu tô dizendo.
Então vale a pena assim você pegar de um
bom fornecedor que deixe claro que
aquele magnésio tá quelado, tá? Porque o
quelado tem que ser bisiglicinato, tá? A
gente usa o termo magnésio glicina, mas
o correto seria falar magnésio
bisglicinato.
Bem, próximo.
Conforme pesquisas mais recentes a
respeito do ômega-3, foram consideradas
situações onde causa arritmias e
assistir o seu vídeo. Eu falei sobre
isso, sim. Como é que fica a situação
pro meu caso que tem um prolapso mitral?
Prápis mitral não quer dizer que
necessariamente tem arritmia, né?
e que já tem arritmias raramente, tá?
Arretmia é uma coisa, mitral é outra,
não são a mesma coisa, tá? É recomendado
tomar. Se eu fosse você, eu tomaria, a
não ser que sua ritminha seja grave, tá?
Isso é polêmico, você vai ouvir
diferentes opiniões a respeito disso aí,
mas doses, digamos, de duas, três
cápsulas para você seria bem seguro a
princípio, tá?
A questão da arritmia da fibrilação
arterial, ela é polêmica
e tá mais associado ao uso de doses
elevadas mais de 4 g por dia.
Se você usar essa dose de até três
cápsulas por dia, você vai ter muito
mais proteção do que problema,
a não ser que seja provado que você
tomou dose baixa e piorou a arritmia,
que eu acho muito difícil, tá?
E você pode também associar taurina, que
é muito bom para estabilizar frequência
cardíaca, com enzima, que é 10 e
carnitina, seria excelente, tá? Além do
próprio magnésio também, que ajuda
bastante na frequência cardíaca.
Tá bom?
Vamos pra próxima. Doutor, em relação ao
vídeo sobre remédios e suplementação pro
sono, o senhor já teve experiência
positiva? Só cri com desmame de
medicamento. Lógico que eu tive. Caso
positivo. Houve realmente suspensão do
medicamento? Houve, mas demora, mas é
rápido. Ou redução de doses teve caso
aqui que não não conseguimos suspender,
só conseguimos reduzir a dose. Os as
duas situações foram utilizadas as
dosagens citadas no vídeo. Sim, mas tem
caso que o o que foi citado no vídeo não
funciona, né? Todo mundo que vai
funcionar as coisas, né? Tá bom?
Houve combinação com os suplementos como
GABA. Já tive caso que eu usei GABA
também. O GABA ele só vai funcionar
mesmo para quem tem algum tipo de leck
brain, né? Ou seja, a pessoa tem algum
tipo de comprometimento da barreira
emcefálica,
tá? Ah, então já tive de tudo. Tive
gente que não desmamou, já teve gente
que desmamou, já teve gente que só
reduziu dose. Depende de cada caso. Tem
gente aí que tem umas insônias brutais
que não consegue resolver com nada,
entendeu?
A redução é sempre personalizada, sempre
lenta, tá? Tem gente que tem uma
dependência muito grande, tem outras
pessoas que têm menos dependência. É
muito individual isso aí, tá?
O GABA também, né? Todo mundo que
funciona. Tem gente que responde muito
bem ao Gaba, tem gente que não responde,
infelizmente. Tá
bem, vamos paraa próxima aqui. Doutor,
na live recente da homeopatia foi citado
sobre o uso de vício com álbum. Sim,
entendi que ele é praticamente um
análogo? Não, não é análogo del não. Ele
funciona de uma maneira diferente, né?
Ele tem algumas ações dele que é
parecido o RDN porque ele vai modular o
sistema imune, mas não é que ele seja
igual. Uma coisa que ele é bem parecido
com a LDN que ele ele induz a popctose,
né, que é morte celular programada,
tá? Mas ele ele é bem diferente
quimicamente o LDN, tá? Tem um mecanismo
de ação diferente.
O que eles têm em comum é que eles ambos
atuam na modulação imunológica e também
nervoso central.
Ah, o Dudu poderia citar algo
relacionado à doses utilizadas na
prevenção, tratamento de câncer. Eu não
tenho muita experiência com o Visco
álbum, mas durante a live eles falaram
lá que tem a forma dose entre aspas alta
e tem a forma homeopática, né? E os
protocolos variam muito conforme o
fabricante, né? E também variam muito de
acordo com que tipo de árvore foi
extraído, como ele falou lá na live, né?
Eu não sou especialista em viscoal, quem
é o doutor lá Lucas, né? Que ele é
especialista. E geralmente a via mais
comum é via subcutânea, mas existe
introvenoso, existe oral, existe
homeopático.
Pessoas assim que tm doença autoimunes
falaram que é melhor utilizar a forma
homeopática. Pessoas que t o câncer, é
melhor utilizar a forma não homeopática.
Você pode começar com 0,01 mg até 1 mg
de uma a 13 semana.
As doses são aumentadas conforme a
tourabilidade do paciente, mas o Luiz
Sterne falou que geralmente é bem
tolerado.
Eh, geralmente para uso homeopático a
potência de três CHS, tá?
Então tem bastante variações aí de doses
aí, tá? E seria interessante você
eh consumir o material aí do Dr. Lucas,
que ele é especialista nisso.
Dr. Luiz Terne trouxe uso de homeopatia
no tratamento do câncer, o mercúrio
solubilis,
um M diário com evolução positiva do
caso em três meses de tratamento. Veja
bem, isso aqui não é uma
receita de bolo, tá? pelo amor de Deus,
ele usa milhares de substâncias
diferentes do tratamento dele. Em
pesquisa identifiquei que 1 m significa
que uma dição de um para 100 feito 1000
vezes. Sim, praticamente não tem mais
nada lá. É o número abaixo, o número de
avogrado, que é a grande crítica que o
pessoal faz a homeopatia. Como o doutor
está estudando? Não, não estou
estudando. Eu vou começar a estudar
ainda, tá? Eu tenho noções de
homeopatia, entendo um pouquinho de
homotoxicológica, mas eu não sou
homeopata. Eu gostaria de entender como
um medicamento como uma dição que
praticamente não deixou moléculo, é a
história do número de avogrado, tá? Você
vai ter que dar uma estudadinha no
assunto. Tem vários vídeos no YouTube
falando sobre homeopatia, explicando eh
esse conceito, tá? Quem acredita em
homeopatia, é o conceito é o conceito de
biofísica, tá? Eles entendem que mesmo
super super diluído que a molécula
original deixou um imprint lá, deixou
uma energia, tá, da molécula, tá?
Então essa que é a ideia seria os
solitons, né? É um conceito de sólitons,
que são partículas como se fosse fótons,
tá? Para vocês entenderem, é como se
fosse fótons, mas não é fóton, é uma
coisa um pouco diferente, mas seria a
impressão magnética, vamos dizer assim,
da substância naquele material, tá? Ou a
energia daquela substância naquele
material. Isso para quem acredita, né?
Para quem não acredita que critica
homeopatia, fala que isso aí é besteira,
né?
Tá? Então seria o mecismo biofísico
porque você realmente não consegue
identificar nada da molécula original
porque tá no número abaixo do número de
avogrado, que seria o número eh mínimo
para você poder identificar alguma
molécula, por mais que tenha equipamento
super avançado.
Tá bom? Mas isso que você tá perguntando
é bem a base do conceito da homeopatia
ranemaniana.
Aí eu eu recomendo que se dê uma
estudada no assunto, veja vídeos no
YouTube sobre isso.
Dr. Alan conhece a Puríssima? É, é a
nova empreitada do Flávio Passos, né? Eu
não gostei muito do que ele fez não,
porque ele tá lançando uma plataforma
que a pessoa entra num site ou entra no
aplicativo e coloca lá as queixas dela,
preenche um questionário e aí ele faz um
suplemento sob medida como se fosse uma
receita de manipulação. Na verdade, ele
tá de débitro de manipulação e tá
fazendo isso através da da plataforma,
ou seja, ele tá passando por cima de
médico e de nutricionista, né?
Então, não estou gostando dessa história
da puríssima, não.
Tô achando
bem complicadinho, tá?
Deixa eu só
ver uma coisinha rapidinho aqui.
Pronto. Próximo.
Quando uma pessoa sente na garganta que
vai vir gripe, a vitamina, que que é
CPPDE, que que é isso? Entendi. Tr que é
isso?
Pode ser o comprado da farmácia
Vitergil. Ah, deve ser vitamina C, né? A
vitamina C pode evitar sim, você pode
usar vitamina C em altas doses para
cortar a gripe
ou a virose mais rápido. A ideia é essa.
Pode ser o comprado da ramassa, vitejil,
pode, mas o problema é que tem que seres
altas, né? protocolos automoleculares
para gripe ou para virose, você tem que
tomar, tipo,
começa tomando 1 g, 2 g, 3 g, 4 g, 5 g,
chega a 50 g, tá? Na verdade, o
protocolo prevê que você vai aumentando
a dose até da diarreia. Deu diarreia,
você recua na dose, tá? E geralmente
ah, você toma de hora em hora ou a cada
2 horas e 1 g de vitamina C. Isso
geralmente retarda, retarda não, ele
abrevia a doença em dois a três dias,
tá?
OK.
Doutor Alan, você disse em live anterior
que tinha omega3 para cérebro, é o DHA,
docosa exenoico e coração é o EPA e cosa
pentenico. Indica um específico da
Vitafor para cérebro, é só você pegar um
um ômega-3 rico em DHA, tá? Tem o, no
caso do Vitafoto é o mega DHA, tá?
Ele tem alta concentração de DHA, que é
esse componente que o cérebro usa mais
para membrana celular, né, do neurônio,
etc. vai melhorar foco, tensão, funções
cognitivas, memória, tá? No caso da
desse da Vitaf Mega DHA, ele tem 1500 mg
de DHA e só vai ter 300 de EPA, então
ele é bem mais direcionado pra saúde
cerebral mesmo. E a Vitafora é uma das
marcas mais
reconhecidas no Brasil de qualidade.
Pode ajudar também na retina em olho,
né? eh, junto com as taxantinas,
achantina e proteína, tá? E é
fundamental para qualquer doença
neurodegenerativa.
Doutor, gosta de saber quais opções para
reduzir os efeitos da neuropatia causada
pela quimioterapia e tratamento câncer
de mama. Uma delas é o LDN, que eu falei
na minha lá, na minha aula lá no
congresso. RDN ajuda a reduzir os
efeitos da neuropatia causada pela
químia. O alfalipôico também é outro que
vai ajudar a diminuir o formigamento,
dor, pera de sensibilidade, tá? Então,
LDN alfalipoico,
você pode usar alguns remédios
anticonvulsivo, ansiose baixa, como é o
caso, por exemplo, da pregabalina ou
gavapentina.
Você
pode usar creme tópico com capsaicina,
que é um derivado da pimenta vermelha,
também tem ação interessante.
[Música]
Você pode usar acupuntura, reflexologia,
yoga, microfisioterapia, pode usar
osteopatia, pode usar quiropraxia,
que mais? Eletroestimulação, pode usar
fotobiomodulação,
que é luz, né?
[Música]
E é isso, vamos responder próxima.
Doutor, boa noite. Gostaria de saber aí,
já respondi essa que tá repetida, tá?
Vamos responder umas poucas perguntas ao
vivo e a gente vai encerrar, tá bom? Boa
noite, Rosiane. Boa noite,
Patrícia. Boa noite, Alice.
Boa noite, Ton Renato.
Obrigado pelo comentário.
É, teve o problema lá da queda de
energia.
Boa noite, Cleidan Matias,
boa noite, Regiane,
vocês até ouviram eu conversando com o
meu pai no telefone, né?
Ã,
já respondi essa pergunta
não fica eficiente. Não é bem assim não,
viu? Ô Patrícia, tá? Não é bem assim
não. Eu concordo que o fígado é uma boa,
mas não faz muito sentido. Vai aumentar
o ferro mais rápido que a ferritina. Eh,
resumindo a história, tá? Resumindo a
história.
Boa noite a todos. Marlon, Denise,
Anelore.
Beberina pode atrapalhar a absorção de
outros nutrientes? Não, a beberina ela
interfere com metabolismo de algumas
drogas. Ela pode aumentar,
por exemplo, os níveis no sangue de
alguns antipertensivos, tá? Tem que
tomar cuidado só com isso, mas não
atrapalhar a absorção que eu saiba, não,
tá?
Nak três vezes ao dia com alimax,
óleo de orégano e beberinha, tá? Isso
são são anti bióticos e antiicrobianos
naturais, né? para disbiose.
Eh,
depende. Eh, se você tivesse
intolerância à estamina, poderia ser uma
dose alta, mas sendo uma pessoa normal,
o NC vai desfazer biofilme, né? Então
ele ajuda na desbiose.
Sim, manipular é bem melhor, mais
seguro. Concordo.
Boa explicação.
Boa noite.
Sim, aosquer começou a usar muito
própolis verde de uns meses para cá.
Ã,
pode ser biscinato, mas pode ser outras
formas de de magnésio queelado também.
Ah, na no caso dessa massa que eu
trabalho, viu, Maria Helena, eu não
deixo de colocar corante, tá? Mas é bem
comum mesmo.
A homeopatia funciona porque ela
transfere informação energética. Isso
que eu falei na pergunta.
Boa noite, Marinete.
Ã,
respondi o questionário da Puríssima, só
curiosidade. Na fórmula que me
indicaram,
tem ferro sem saber que o ferro está em
excesso para mim. Também não gostei. É,
não vai ter personalização decente isso
daí, né? Essa que é a verdade. O cara tá
querendo ganhar dinheiro à custas aí dos
profissionais de saúde. Essa que é a
verdade, tá? Para ele é ótimo, né? Ele
já é milionário, vai ficar mais
milionário ainda, né? O problema é que
deve ter uma equipe de advogado para
cuidar disso aí também, né? Que ele vai
vai ter problema com certeza com os
conselhos e tudo mais, mas ele tá nem aí
porque tem grana para caramba, né?
Ã,
se ela tem problema de mioma, ela quer
fazer raio X total? Não entendi essa
pergunta não.
Não entendi o que você quer dizer com
isso.
De nada.
Gente, então acho que eu vou encerrar,
né?
Quase uma hora de live. Vou ficar mais 2
minutos, tá? Para vocês interagirem um
pouco aqui comigo.
F mais cabelo meu, tá horrível. Preciso
cortar o cabelo, cara.
Ainda nem fiz a baba hoje também.
Ah, se ela pode acrescentar raio X aos
exames.
X para ver o quê? Mioma não vai aparecer
no raio X, não. Só se for mi
calcificado.
Mioma você avalia com traçõ às vezes com
exame de ressonância.
Onde compro o corebiome? Farmácia e
manipulação integritar.
integritar.com.br.
Per, deixa eu ver se eu tenho aqui nas,
eu acho que eu tenho aqui na
em algum lugar aqui. Pera aí.
Ah, cadê? Cadê? Cadê?
Não, não deve ter não. Tem tanta coisa
escrita aqui. Deixa eu ter que apagar a
maioria aqui. Bem, vou colocar aqui
integritar.com.br.
B. Pronto.
Esse aqui, ó. Pronto. Tá bom.
Tá bom, Claudine, nessa farmácia aí. Tá
OK. Já temos uma hora de live, então vou
encerrar. Muito obrigado a vocês pela
participação.
Não gosto muito. Você fala de gosto
pessoal. ou se é um bom alimento. Se for
de gosto pessoal, mais ou menos. Não
gosto muito de carne de porco, não. Como
alimento é muito parecido com carne de
de de boi. O pessoal pensa que carne
de
de porco é carne branca, mas não é. Tá
bom.
Ah, não sei, Mar, não sei. Boa pergunta.
Tô meio desligado sobre isso daí.
Sim. Então ele é bem parecido com carne
de vaca. Pessoal, muito obrigado. Vou
encerrar aqui porque alguém resolveu
fazer uma obra aqui no prédio e vai
atrapalhar a live. Beijo. Até semana que
vem.